all right now I have over here because I
wanted everything on the board so you
could see I have one more that I wanted
to do which is going to clue you in to
what's going on and that is x squared
now this again is a function you've been
working with for a long time and you've
also been working with its inverse
function you've been doing it probably
since you were doing Pythagoras because
what is the inverse function of square
root it's the square root right now this
gets at the heart of why I'm asking us
to wait for sine X until later on
probably this is lisa is going to do
this for you what does x squared look
like and how does it look in comparison
to the square root of x we know what
experi you can let trace it out you were
started to draw in your mind already
right here it is there is x squared are
you happy with that now what does the
square root of x look like well it
begins at the origin right here and then
here's the shape there it is that's the
square root of x I should label it
should know F inverse okay let's do two
things with this number one can you
again turn your page 45 degrees right do
you see the line of symmetry going
through go ahead draw if you've got that
other color just like we have in all of
these cases the square root of x just
like every other inverse in the world is
a reflection that's a really bad one
keyline sorry across y equals x you can
see it sort of comes in and curves out
it's a really nice symmetry actually
that I don't know if you have ever
spotted before until it's highlighted
for you that's the first thing I want
you to notice the second thing is it's
not a complete reflection is it it's
missing part which part is that miss you
where would it be if I reflected the
whole thing yeah it'll be down here
right it would be down here why do we
not have this guy down here it's it's
the same as the reason we don't have
everything here in sine inverse of X it
wouldn't be this guy here if you
included there would not be a function
would it because it would violate the
vertical line test like everywhere
except for the origin okay so because we
want the square root to be a function
because that's useful to us we say are
we going to cut that guy out okay
we're only going to look at this
particular part of f of X this is really
important write this down underneath
when you've drawn or beside where you've
drawn this one we restrict the domain we
restrict the domain of f of X the
original what do we restrict it to which
part of f of X do we look at and then
reflect we look at I think it's domain
right its domain X's or wise its X's and
you can remember it's alphabetical right
domain and range X's and Y's we restrict
the domain of f of X to X is
hmm have a look which part gets
reflected does this part over here get
reflected yeah we want greater than or
equal to zero we're okay with zero that
guy is fine so we're gonna say X is
greater than or equal to zero okay we
chose that part and then we reflected it
okay now one of the weird things is you
didn't have to choose that part we
didn't have to we could have looked at
this part instead and we could still
have reflected that you would have still
gotten to function why do you think we
chose this part rather than the other
side it's positive I like positive
numbers but just because someone likes
something is not a good reason to say
everyone everywhere and everyone's
calculators should just be this part
over here or sorry I should say this
pile over here why is this useful I want
to remind you again where did we first
meet square roots
we must first met square roots when
we're trying to work out hey you have a
sign over here right you try to find out
what it is
you got three you got four and you would
say oh that's going to be that
hypotenuse there right
that'll be h squared equals 3 squared
plus 4 squared and you have to invoke
the square root function right now it
would be kind of weird if we said well
XH squared equals 25 H is going to be
the square root of 25
oh that's restricted to the negative
value that would be really weird right
square roots emerged in the context of
measurement and in measurement things
are positive yeah so therefore if I'm
going to get if I want positive values
out of this I might as well restricted
to the positive values that make sense
okay I need most place to point out one
more thing and then we're gonna let you
have a go at actually using these things
and manipulating them okay I said right
at the beginning there's a runoff this
side here I said right at the beginning
that an inverse will just sort of
reverse the direction or turn something
inside out upside down okay so therefore
you can do one last fancy algebraic
trick with something like an inverse
right if you have a function like
addition right and then you apply the
inverse which is subtraction what do you
get out the other end you just get well
these two things they cancel so you get
X right what if you did it with
multiplication if you had a function and
then you applied its inverse what would
you get now every single time this
happens you can look at all of your
other examples okay
so therefore if I'm using this sum see
this weird FX F inverse notation how
would I say this I could say if you took
f of X and then you applied its inverse
maybe I should have put square brackets
to make that a little bit clearer
no matter what the function you started
with was if your plants inverse what
should you end up with X every time
would it make a difference if I did it
in the other order will it make a
difference if I thought about the
inverse and then applied the original
function to that would it make a
difference now because look you could do
X on two right start with that guy and
then apply the original function to X
and you're still going to end up with X
okay so this here is really really
important
what a big box around it in some ways
it's the definition in fact you only
really need the top one it's the
definition of an inverse function this
is what makes an inverse what it is and
mathematicians really love writing
things like this because they're so
succinct no flowery words in the way or
no pictures I like the pictures though
because they help you get a sense of
what's happening but this is what the
definition is boiled down to the lowest
okay